les séparatistes pro-russes film avec un
drone leur dernière prise la localité de
nouveaux kiffe ce qu'est dans le donbass
ils tiennent désormais cette commune
mais c'est un champ de ruines thil
contrôler ces images illustrent la
légère avancée des troupes russes dans
l'est de l'ukraine
dans la région de kharkiv deuxième ville
du pays mais aussi dans quelques autres
localités des percées russe que les
autorités ukrainiennes reconnaissent
dans la direction de severodonezk les
envahisseurs ont pris le contrôle de
plusieurs localités et mène une
offensive en direction de deux autres
comme une
autre image fournie par les russes ces
lancements de missiles qui aurait eu
lieu en mer noire ils auraient permis
selon moscou de détruire en ukraine une
grande quantité d'armement livré par
l'occident autre sujet d'inquiétude la
moldavie ou plus exactement la
transnistrie cette région séparatiste
pro-russe hier une explosion il ya par
exemple endommagé cette tour radio pas
d'indication sur l'origine des frappes
dès attaques qui font craindre un
embrasement aussi dans cette région la
présidente moldave pro européenne
s'alarme analyse hélène notre analyse
montre qu'il existe des tensions entre
les forces de la région
certaines cherchent à déstabiliser la
situation
malgré ces tensions les autorités
moldaves appelle la population au plus
grand calme